i was born in
in i was born in soviet in 1977.
i i
i was born soviet and everybody knows
soviet school of figure skating is the
best school
and i was three and a half years old my
grandmother took me to the rink
and i loved it so much and then by the
age of seven eight i knew this is what i
want to do
i did know that
so when my mother passed at 13
i was alone but i hold on to my skates
and they took me all the way
to the top
what's going on right now
everybody
is supporting what's happening in my
country
the whole world is
behind
ukrainian people who are dying for no
reason
in on in ukrainian land
nancy carey again a few days ago on
february 26 that was the anniversary
for me winning the gold medal for the
country of ukraine came out
publicly and said
girl
i'm thinking about you
and all the prayers
to the people of your country
and that was the second or third day
when
the
invasion happened
and by the end of the day because i was
crying for the first of couple of days
i
i don't i don't like the word shock but
i am in disbelief still
and every day is getting worse and worse
and worse and worse what's happening
on the ukrainian soil on the ukrainian
land
that
till yesterday i was able to get in
touch with my people back
in ukraine for the first couple days
and
in the last
day or so
it's just not possible especially right
now in kharkiv
the city of kharkiv
is completely bumped
it's
it's
it's
it's just so sad it's
i am in disbelief
i've been asked a question
do you still have family and relatives
there and i said yes i do
because everybody knows
sportsmanship
is a big huge family around the world
i
hate being political but
people have to understand
one week ago kharkiv the city of kharkiv
in ukraine was hosting
a figure skating event for the juniors
so
a lot of kids came to take participation
in that event
and then war started happening the
bombing started happening
and
and they just got stuck there for the
first couple of days
till
they were able to find
people
and transportation how to send them back
to their cities because
it's unthinkable what's going on in
ukraine it's
it's just not fair it's it's
i mean
normal regular people who have done
absolutely nothing
to russia and we have been brothers and
sisters
forever
we are
we we're we we love each other and
what's going on right now
it should it shouldn't be
there is a lot of people who are russian
speaking people
i
i have nothing against russian people
and a lot of them they're texting me and
they're saying we don't want this to
happen daksana
this is not us
i actually called today to one of my
really dear friends
and
she was start crying on the phone and i
said why are you crying and she said
because
i have no words for what's going on
there i said don't when you will come to
las vegas i will give you the biggest
hug
it's it's the rally for everybody the
reason is why yesterday i decided to
speak up for people because this morning
i texted to ukrainian community and i
delivered the poster to them
and their response was
oksana please speak up for us
please we love to see the pictures
we enjoy
knowing
sitting in the bomb shelters
that
people care for us and they're
there for us
that is the reason why i'm doing this
rally
i just wanted to say thank you to las
vegas because
28 years ago that was my first stop in
america
yep
yep and i was 16 years old and i was
trying to gamble and then security came
and said i'm not allowed
i didn't even speak english back then
i was like what are you saying
because cultural differences is very
different in america and ukraine
and people have to understand
this is not a political statement i'm
trying to make
this is a humanitarian statement
the reason is why because
the mothers and kids are dying right now
there are being bombed
and there is nothing more
we can do other than being
out there supporting them
and being their
voices well ukrainian people have their
own national anthem
and
at 16 i
stand up on the toughest podium
and
that national anthem played at the
olympic games for the first time
we have our own culture we have our own
songs we have that is that is actually
what they're doing right now
because they were able to go back and
forth to their apartments now they're
not able to because bombing is really
intense
so some men they have guitars
and they're sitting in the bomb shelters
with their pets without food without
diapers without medicine
singing the
songs trying to
stay
hopeful and cheerful
and
we have our own cuisine everybody knows
borsch
it's ukrainian traditional soup
so that's pretty much what's ukraine
yes ukraine
ukraine needs help right now ukraine
needs prayers
yes absolutely on saturday at well first
of all
for
carlo i'm looking for the word what's
the name of that building sweetie
city hall
yes yes yes
yesterday
city hall
turned
it lights to blue and yellow to the
national colors
of ukrainian flag
and when i did
do you see that
i said to myself
i'm gonna do the rally and i'm gonna
invite everyone
and i just wanna thank them
for
their support
a lot of a lot of people
they're
trying to get in touch and they're
trying to plea for help
they're
they're saying
can we please get the numbers
of the attorneys who we can get in touch
with
so
the refugee crisis in ukraine is
probably right now is the number one
problem
and when i speak to
my skating friends who are in ukraine
they're telling me aksana we can leave
we can go to poland we can go to
hungary we can go to a lot of different
countries right now
they would have to walk to the border
lines
but we don't want to leave our land
this is our homes
and they're pleading
they're
they're saying
they're asking of me to say
we're winning the war
on the land what they're doing is if
they see tanks coming towards the cities
they're covering up
the entry to the city with their bodies
basically
they're standing and holding the tanks
and they're pushing them back
so
they're saying would you be so kind to
say
we need no fly
zone on top of the country because we're
being bombed
very heavily heavily and every day it's
more and more and more
and refugee crisis i mean they
i've said it before they getting
they're running out of
everything pretty much
so they do need in some cases
yes yes they there are
a lot a lot of refugees
a lot of refugees they they do so what
i'm asking
is i mean i'm still sitting and
i don't know yet but
if the people cannot open their wallets
please open their heart and pray for
them